speaking of ridiculous internet content
or we got our boy back our boy dropped
something on the Twitter's did he really
we got it oh [ __ ] yeah we got to do this
yes ladies and gentlemen it's our
favorite the one I know we can I just
say before we even get into this yeah
SiC fit yeah but my boy is Deborah this
is a New Year's fit what are we talking
here is it New Year's Eve okay he's got
a vest on he got the wreath you got the
Thanksgiving wreath out in front of him
yep he's looking directly into a wreath
a little bit late it is New Year's but
he's not Eve and this is still I think
people leave that show for New Year's
yeah no one takes it down right after
Christmas you know decorated and tumors
and yeah Quidditch snitches tumors and
snitches all right let's see you it was
here our boy has to say tell us what's
it about
Oh weird way to start that this is like
a [ __ ] valedictorian speech right off
the bat just son there's some rush it
right there already
what's this year what's it been about
what's it about
what man run that baby what am i high
running back a little
I'm looking for 2020 and my trippin was
that not a sentence no no it's like
Trump out in the middle of thousand
twenty what the [ __ ] is happening what
that doesn't make sense right 2020
what's that about well it 2019 it'd be a
lot cooler if you did let's let the
sudden finish let's let him finish look
for 2020 to be a lot cooler because we
do
oh is it supposed to make no sense I'm
[ __ ] up right now this [ __ ] me up
who's this Russian baby behind him this
is Jung Borislav behind them that
[ __ ] nav ass haircut Edgar as Eric
yeah where is he
post it up in Moscow New Year's Eve in
Moscow drinking some Long Branch that's
why he gained some pork cracklin pork
cracklins no no I'm still [ __ ] up from
this I don't know what this I don't know
what the [ __ ] that and so some somebody
said that we underestimate Matthew
McConaughey's sex appeal and that he is
so sexy that it doesn't matter what he
does women want to know that's what
someone told us yeah I get that but that
doesn't what we're not really under
estimating that I don't think so are
they saying that it he doesn't have to
make sense and he doesn't have to do
these things yeah he can be [ __ ]
weird as [ __ ] yeah but because girls he
knows that girl's welcome because we
said who the [ __ ] cares about this and
then this young woman is saying we do
you we want to [ __ ] him so bad
oh okay so yeah we want to know
everything he's doing but he hears ears
here's the real here's the real treat
here what here's the real treat let's
see who is actually gonna lie and
pretend like they understood what the
[ __ ] you said Clinton his real eyes
click the threat let's look at these
replies let's see let's see you full of
it oh my god okay whatever
don't care that's an awesome [ __ ]
background that's [ __ ] sick dude send
me that [ __ ]
true detective three twenty twenty let's
go Matt all right okay what what is this
now no I okay that makes no sense is
garbage this is just [ __ ] garbage uh
put her [ __ ] sucks dude look at this
though God Almighty Megan is drooling
for Matthew McConaughey that face their
face is like xanax
yeah what let me ask you this Megan what
the [ __ ] did he say what does it mean it
doesn't matter they're all they love you
Matthew happy and healthy New Year to
you and your friend look at this yeah
this is just
I wonder if Matthew think Matthews
[ __ ] reading these replies well happy
New Year to you too Karen here we go
Dickey Rex he's on our team he's faded
Happy New Year minions yeah but he's
faded off the long brain a Long Branch
faded off a couple pork cracklins oh
yeah those are all just thirst traps is
that cover picture is amazing look at
this man
look horns at where [ __ ] honk horns
horns up [ __ ] is it yeah yeah hook em
hook em hook em baby I don't want my
horns before I give a TED talk on how to
wrangle the bull what doth 2020 is too
you may not oh my god
2019 should be for others and for what I
recommend for you going into 2020
focus on the hi
and what it what adults be you welcome
oh my god
I am spent by a Buick honey are you okay
in there huh yeah oh [ __ ] son you know
what like he's what if he's just he just
knows that he's [ __ ] at another level
yeah definitely what it is he knows he's
at you know crazy [ __ ] space level
above us and what just in general and
like everything he knows he can just
make a video like this and make no sense
yeah on purpose
mmm-hmm rub it in our faces mm-hmm and
still just collect mm-hmm yeah yeah I is
he married I think Matthew McConaughey's
[ __ ] married is he like dating
Matthew McConaughey Fox and that's it
okay he only box he only bugs doesn't
even make movies anymore just [ __ ] yeah
that's all yes just [ __ ] he posts he
[ __ ] posts he's the dream guy right
now on the Internet
ironically you know when he walked on to
Texas whatever University and he would
he set foot on campus you know many
[ __ ] wedding rings just liquefied you
know just levitated off yeah they all
came together cuz they were all 10 karat
gold um you know men uh medium income
husband's and they all molded into an
Emmy yeah yeah they received a
pre-emptive Emmy for the performance he
was gonna give at that college and he
just walked onto campus and said
let me take a cover photo from my
Twitter my oh my
it's amazing what rings can do when they
come together interesting word
together just you and a pork cracklin
pork cracklin [ __ ] you know how know
how know like what percentage of dude
can take a video of i'm sipping Long
Branch and a pork cracklin ever be sexy
oh yeah word yo me a word pork cracklin
yeah crackling pork crackling hacklin
you my little pork cracklin I'm trying
to smoke some pork crap you know any
[ __ ] hash tag bourbon dudes I've
tried that acid that bourbon did yeah
hashtag bourbon dudes
hashtag search the hashtag Bourbon dad
some Club for Bourbon dad's dad's
interested in bourbon bourbon dude no
dad both let's see we get its bourbon
Society it's burning society
[ __ ]
Oh Pig Panther calm suburban guy would
have beard with the pork cracklin in the
Long Branch sipping some 1948
taking after another gentleman such as
Matthew sipping some Long Branch and he
has one comment from another bourbon
fanuc yeah it's like follow us for hot
bourbon tips he just send their
refreshing bourbon tip give me a good
bourbon tip right now mmm when sipping
Long Branch zip three seconds at a time
and you can really for optimal palate
yeah and you can really catch the Long
Branch flavor yeah okay when it was
distilled in a barrel it was done in
the Cedar Oakwood okay which has a
specific property in the wood that can
only be tasted with long gestured sips
oh now that's a hot bourbon tip everyone
yes
hashtag bourbon tip hashtag bourbon dude
hashtag bourbon dad I coulda says a
funnier like you should save it before
beating your meat but I had to go with
the [ __ ] most literal I'm an idiot
anyway yeah I just wanted to check in
with our boy you know Stan new year we
had to see what he was talking about
yeah top of your bourbon dude yes of you
bourbon man if you have any bourbon tips
blow up the comments with your bourbon
tips we want to know yeah you this is
officially the Bourbon dudes podcast
bourbon and beer guys podcast yeah we
got to grow some sick beer it's [ __ ]
by some cyber trucks
you